hey man it's filthy [ __ ] rich
simcity money man sim guy big five nine
man check me out on bootleg cab podcast
man it's filthy
yo boo like kev podcast special guest in
here one of my first guests on the show
ever
he's officially back first yeah i think
you were like uh in the first like six
or seven episodes when we were doing the
chairs in here
filthy rich is here what's up man
chillin chilling man in town for today
uh you are in town for the day
is this new jewelry you got
uh
i don't know i've been having for a
while it's a um some serious change you
have
serious one inside of my boy wifey wifey
made both of these i was gonna say like
the actual links
those diamonds are like those are those
are siri that's not no normal [ __ ] no we
don't do normal around here nothing
normal man um you got the new album out
motivational purposes yeah great title
um i do feel like you've uh
probably been the source of motivation
and inspiration for a lot of people in
terms of just
being an independent boss
being a businessman being somebody who
has done um
you know when it comes to just longevity
in the rap game not a lot of people have
longevity not people can
support themselves for the amount of
time that you've been able to do so you
know like you got to know how to rap
hustle
rap hustle break that down
um
doing like everything that comes around
rap
if it's versus if it's videos if it's
um
you know different people endorse you
like you got to know how to really get
off your ass and get to it like a lot of
people just be content
and just sit back and you know like okay
so really
i kind of like i seen jim one night we
was out
jim jones yeah okay and he was like um
he had like three different shows did
like four verses in one night and like
one guy was like for ten
ten twenty thousand another guy he went
over there and had like 7500 like he
wasn't turning down nothing just getting
running it over this not saying that he
was doing the same amount of work for
the
for the lower but he wasn't turning down
nothing so you got to get up and rap
hustle
yeah i think like if you're independent
and you know there's definitely like
there's a way to just super monetize
what you're doing yeah and then you know
what rapping all type of different
things come like um chelsea just hit me
right now and red bull want me to do
something
uh like a freestyle on the block mm-hmm
and uh they're supposed to be paying me
for it or whatever then i i just started
doing the cameo thing to where you do
all you're going cameo and people can
like yo if they want to if you want to
do a drop for you or like a happy
birthday so it's like so many different
opportunities that rap bring to you that
you can you know hustle
yeah i think that a lot of artists leave
money on the table yeah a lot of people
because if you're just depending on i
never wanted to do that at first like
the
shout out stuff right i never did it in
one day i'm like man let me see i think
i made like three thousand and one cameo
no now cam yeah i just started right now
just off my own oh god you got you yeah
are you talking about like if someone
like says hey
to pay phil
pay my shout out my store yeah and then
at first i never was doing that [ __ ]
like i've seen a lot of rappers doing
that [ __ ] through the pandemic boozy be
doing that [ __ ]
i'm like man let me see somebody was
like hey man i give 500 posts on the
story for me
my cash happened to me he sent it and i
posted i'm like oh there's something
here yeah but i never uh they been
asking me to do i give you 2 000 to post
me on your page i'm like hell night
posting on my page
i'm like i just think that there's like
a stigma that i think is probably like
not
accurate in terms of like
you know i think there's certain artists
that like that might not make sense for
if you're if you're like the weeknd or
you're like but if you're an independent
artist and sure you should be doing it
you should be running it up man listen
that [ __ ] it's good luck
right now and i already got like two of
them already sent well think about it
you just said you got
uh
what's the most amount of money you've
gotten for a ig shout out on the story
yeah i just charged 500. so 500 bucks
for people who don't know
500
is
if a million streams is four bands
500 my math might be [ __ ] up here
500 bucks is
is that 100 000 streams
i don't know about the streams
but feel me like you got to do like a
serious chunk of streams to make some
good money yeah cause i know one day i
made like
like three g's just like on some back
them like damn you'd have to do it by
everybody coming to me well you would
have to do almost a million streams on a
record to get that to get that money
yeah and that was what six people it's
really a matter of using the music using
the catalog to open up all this other
revenue yeah first i started like at 250
and then i went up to like 500. and then
obviously using the rap money using um
all of that to just launch other
businesses like we were just talking you
breed dogs about the dog i did a
breeding um yesterday and today
i got puppies i be doing dog shows they
pay me do dog shows i host judge all
type of [ __ ] but that comes from being a
rapper
how long did uh have you been doing the
dog the dog breeding um
i think i got my first dog that i
started doing the reading with probably
like just maybe five years ago
serious money man
serious money like um
it's a lot of responsibility yeah um i
had like i had a whole kennel
i had built a whole kennel i spent like
250 on like uh
the house um the backyard and i built
the like
like a house in the backyard for the
dogs here that had like 10 um slots to
eat in inside of the house right with
the drains where they piss and [ __ ] and
go down to the sewer wash out
um marble floor ac unit
high water heater your dogs are living
living better than some dudes for sure
living better than a lot of people yeah
so i mean because i know there's a lot
of money involved so you got to take
good care of it yeah no with the dog
thing it's like like you said you got to
take good care of him it's a it's a
messy it's a messy thing
you got to make sure you know like i'll
be trying to convince my wife i'm like
babe like
you know because we got the plug this is
the main objective though it's the
longevity yeah you get we're going to
get this money you have to clean up some
dog [ __ ] i might have to jerk off a dog
you know every once in a while but
dude when you stud your dogs do you ever
do manually i've never done it you don't
have to ask that question that happens
at the vet that happens so you take it
to the vet yes so my boy they do it he
does it himself he says it's better than
the vet
i don't know how they do it they take
the female and they take the male
the male smells their they do it right
there and then they do it like that i've
never done it i never will do it yeah
because i mean i guess like whatever
downside to like going to the vet like
to me the real downside i just don't
even want to pay the money well the real
downside is jerking off your dog
yeah too but i just feel like you know
it was always
cutting corners with this [ __ ] so it's
like right cool instead of me paying the
vet to do it and then they i've also
seen people at home they take the semen
and put it in the girl right i've seen
them man i didn't win somewhere and they
put the dog to sleep in front of you
through the surgery in front do
everything one stop shot so what kind of
dogs are you doing english
english bulldogs now i've had two
english bulldogs
my first english bulldog really didn't
have any health problems my second one
did but i always would hear you know i
got my bulldogs like
that they always have health issues um
they're exotic so that's why you can't
even breed them like normally also yeah
they also can't [ __ ] like that they
can't swim they can't they can't
[ __ ] like that listen i've thrown my
english bulldog into a pool you swam but
with that being said probably not the
best idea yeah uh because they get tired
they have breathing problems they have
small tracheas
um like sometimes they can't eat like
bigger food gotta make the food softer
and they slobber a lot yeah well mine
don't really slide without mine listen i
let them out running back in the cage
that they they all they're good i used
to take my dog to the car they've been
hit too long yeah no i have man rest in
peace to my guy ari gold yeah that's
what happened to my dog um but yeah nah
they they are very they they're short of
breath that's for sure yeah but i had
one that was like
i never had one like him before this guy
he's chasing the basketball jumping in
the air he was that's how my dog was
yeah he was crazy like i've never had an
english bulldog like him before he was
he was different um what other like uh
business ventures do you you know do you
got your your your your emergency had my
merch uh
i had a clothing i mean uh salon
um but i ended up giving it to my
godmother because due to covet like
people wasn't trying to come in and
people weren't trying to work or
whatever so uh but i'm re um launching
it again but just online
same thing at the closing store same
thing happened so i'm just launching
everything online
um i would still have a modeling company
in the bay area
like 10 females for like
um music videos [ __ ] artists that want
females and videos and that came about
because it was a lot of big rappers that
used to come in town and me and called
me like hey man maybe some some girls
videos girls
i'm like [ __ ] i might as well just start
doing like this so put like 10 females
together
photo shoots calendars um they do
fashion shows video shoots everything
that's good money hey that's real [ __ ]
cuz that's the first thing especially
here like in la it happens all the time
like i have someone come to lao i need
some hoes for my shoot and i'm like bro
do i look like the whole guy like i'm
[ __ ]
i'm married bro what you want from me
you know like but that's like
that that's good money in that [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then my record label and i got a uh
got like 10 12 artists
and then um
my charity
giving back what's the charity based
around it's called 50 letter kids
so i've been doing that for like
maybe like 10 years yo and um
like toy drives christmas
thanksgiving
back to school uh we didn't did um
celebrity basketball games in my
neighborhood at the gym
um
sure you name it
yeah gotta stop the interview real quick
gotta tell you about our good folks at
my bookie it's a big weekend in college
basketball we got the final four finally
going the [ __ ] down
i'm taking duke and that boy and coach k
to run that thing up all the way to the
championship baby all right i like
duke kansas
to make the championship game nice
little two team parlay right there go to
my bookie if you want to get down man
and gamble with your boy we're making
this money over here if uh you are in
one of these states and you don't know
how to get your gambling on when it
comes to sports gambling you always see
people talking about it online listen
you gotta go to mybookie.ag
sign up for an account
it's i've been using my bookie for about
eight years and that's no cap no kids
app at all that's straight up facts i
really am a user of my bookie i [ __ ]
with my bookie the long way not only can
you do the sports gambler you could go
on there and play [ __ ] blackjack with
a lady and i don't know what country
she's in but she's she's twisting that
[ __ ] ball you know what i'm
saying and
dealing them cards but go to my bookie
sign up with the promo code bootleg
b-o-o-t-l-e
and when you make a deposit your first
deposit will get matched up to a
thousand dollars ncaa basketball is
about to get wrapped up then we're full
force into the nba playoffs all right
the one-seed phoenix suns just put all
of your money on them
you know they beat the warriors the
other night i don't know if you saw that
cook
i don't know did you see that huh
just put all your money on the suns but
listen let's get this money man i i love
sports gambling y'all know about me i'm
a i just love it i'm very passionate
about it and there's only one place i
put my bets in at it's my bookie and i'm
not saying that just because they
sponsor our podcast that's the truth so
go to mybookie.ag they make it so easy
for you to do parlays the bet uh all
kinds of player props just whatever
futures whatever you want you can bet on
[ __ ] wrestlemania bro so what are we
doing go to mybookie.ag
sign up right now use the promo code
bootleg and they will match your first
deposit free money
up to a thousand dollars let's get back
to the interview would you ever a lot of
artists are
doing only fans management
i don't know what that is it's like uh
only fans management they're only doing
only fans so manage this so like
like tyga who else did we have up here
who's doing that
oh adam 22 does it but he's not a rapper
uh so
blue face blue face perfectly that's
what do you mean man so what blue face
does is
so he has um like an only fans but he
don't [ __ ] on there he just uh it's like
a reality show yeah
but then he manages
uh girls tiger manages girls too
so essentially tiger's on there [ __ ]
okay but tyga will have like um a girl
signed to his agency
and then he promotes them
and then he gets a piece of their only
fans adam 22 is doing the same thing
okay adam 22 said he's got like a top
five earner on only fans that he gets a
chunk of i'm like jesus it's like kind
of like so so what is he like investing
into her or is he just promoting her
promoting her
it's kind of like did it feels like
digital pimping
remember we remember the eight balls i
need to get into it the a ball on mjg
album uh space age pimpin that feels
like what they were talking about yeah i
need to give my girls on my um
[Music]
get them to get them hey get the filthy
models and uh get them all on only fans
and just get your percentage is only
fans still popping though i thought that
[ __ ] was like it was supposed to go away
but they realized
that if they did if they got rid of the
adult content that their business would
be over
and so it's still lit yeah but they're
not paying like they used to i heard
they're like taking that i don't know i
think they think they take longer to pay
out
yeah that i don't know but at the end of
the day i'll be hearing [ __ ] about it
here and there i was going doing a long
time ago not me on there [ __ ] or
nothing but just like showing my
lifestyle like just so much [ __ ] i had
in my phone but they was like oh you got
to get contracts from these girls and
you got to have them sign off on this
and you can't post that [ __ ] just like
going out to the club [ __ ] dancing
twerking fighting it might be a
threesome [ __ ] or [ __ ] might be
[ __ ] each other whatever
you know what i'm saying you know what
you you know what um
uh ddg does uh who's a rapper but he
also he started as a youtuber so ddg uh
on his only fans
pretty much it's a giveaway game
so he'll be like trying to teach you how
to go viral on youtube like um like
batman kevo yeah yeah exactly shout out
to him um similar to yeah they pretty
much like you you just go on there and
you'll be like giving out games yeah i
feel you got a lot of game to give out
yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure but you
could sell it
yeah sellers you guys know how to market
it yeah you just gotta know how to
market it i mean market it with some
hoes too you know what i mean
we'll figure it out sure you got 10
chicks they're called the filthy models
that's team filthy 10 filthy team field
team filthy i like that
what was the name of the uh do you
remember the uh
team of models that were based in miami
in the early 2010s that were late as
[ __ ] what are you talking about
something angels
taz is angels angels tazza's angels
that was what happened to that [ __ ] what
happened to taz
did anybody ever see him yeah i think so
no i thought he was like incognito i
don't know but i just remember everybody
was all these like randomized chicks
were moving like the same thing like
somebody just had some females like
modern [ __ ] prior to only fans imagine
taz's angels be running it up on the
internet mike goodness
he'd have been killing it man yeah that
was way before our only fans uh you who
do you got on the i'm you got i swear
bezel on the project
seti hendrix seti hendrix afn peso
my artist tudor bands the skinny tee
rich the kid
jeremiah
um
should i gotta
look and see do you pay for features at
this point no it's all love
yeah that's i feel like if someone that
i feel like that would be the case
there's certain artists that like i feel
like
it's got to be a respect thing yeah for
sure for sure um i have before in the
back in the day when i didn't
just trying to rap and hey man i want to
hear you on my song type [ __ ] and right
now i know who you are you not knowing
who i am type [ __ ] but you know that
comes to say like that's being biased
because you know [ __ ] buy features for
me all day that's true so yeah i think
it just also depends
like if you got a deal on a drake
feature you'd be like yo
yeah it's something different yeah but
at this point certain features worth
paying for
yeah um they end up being
relationships later on and the features
end up being you know triple double or
whatever type [ __ ] you get i'm saying so
you know it just all depends on how how
to [ __ ] it how it's handled that's some
real [ __ ] man who are you um like right
now just on some fan [ __ ] like outside
of your crew your label what is the
music you're listening to that you enjoy
i really just only listen to
like
all my artists there's so many of them
you feel me so we always uh
critiquing everything i've been trying
to like drop something
every month from the label like on some
real master p type [ __ ] like like a tape
every week running it out yeah like that
so that's how
what's this april march it's about to be
april yeah yeah so we already said april
we're working on may now
in june
so um but other than that like i listen
um
i've been listening to i was i was real
big on baby money out of um detroit
before he got started detroit's going
crazy man baby money hard uh you know i
[ __ ] with the whole detroit sound right
yeah i feel like yeah we always talk
about it on the show like how detroit
and the bay has like a real uh
connection sonically obviously dope game
wise you know all of that you know what
i'm saying me you know i just i love
culture you know what i'm saying a lot
of food the strip clubs the jury the the
get money hustle you feel me all that
[ __ ] you know i i really be out there so
if anybody i could relate to that [ __ ]
detroit's a vibe mm-hmm
um give us don't get it twisted
immediately we got to go to detroit soon
and uh we're going to be
wherever wherever the shit's popping off
at is where we're going to be at because
we got to go shoot with like three or
four artists out there like go see their
where they grew up and [ __ ] so we're
gonna be in the in the thick of it we
was in um i was like stuck out there for
like a week in the snow
i couldn't leave like no flights like
the snow was like oh wow like blocking
the doors what area of the bay are you
from oakland seminary east oakland yeah
we were in um
we were shooting some [ __ ] in vallejo i
won't say with who but uh it was hot man
yeah you won't say with who no i almost
said with
with which artist because it didn't work
out but
we uh pulled up in the in the crest yeah
right off the freeway
sob
no idea he said the crest
[ __ ] was hot let's just say [ __ ] was hot
i mean the bay high period just like
detroit like vallejo richmond san
francisco oakland all that [ __ ] turned
up yeah right now i feel like the bay
right now is kind of like nationally got
a really bad rap because when we see
a lot of the smash and grab [ __ ] when we
see a lot of the um you know homeless
fools going up into the walgreens and
just filling their bag with [ __ ] and
walking it's all because you know in san
francisco like i'll go there once a
month you know for empire [ __ ] and
um
the walgreens like in the city and the
cvs's are closed
themselves is just i don't think it was
like
a bad rap like i feel like like well no
because i think in sam in in the city of
san francisco they got that law
that they can't stop you and the cops
won't prosecute you or arrest you if you
if you shoplift under a thousand dollars
so that's why
so all the petty stuff [ __ ] so you'll
see all these dudes going in on their
bikes just [ __ ] rolling up in the
[ __ ] cvs just do like a smash and
grab out here for like they did at
beverly hills 5 million or something
yeah that [ __ ] was crazy did you see the
video i just heard about it oh the video
is crazy
like yeah i'm like damn he's doing that
[ __ ] everywhere how was that no the
smashing grab shit's everywhere was at a
jeweler in vegas and they told me that
they just came in there and did that
[ __ ] there too that's where it kind of
sucks like if you're in california
like because you can't really like
you know some people pull some [ __ ] like
that in florida they're getting smoked
by the owner yeah california you
probably who if you shoot the guy yeah
you're probably going to go to jail
before he goes to jail yeah it's crazy
like that's just the gun likes and [ __ ]
the gun laws and [ __ ] i think it's gonna
i think it's gonna chill out man in in
cali because i feel like people
are starting to realize i think they was
doing all that [ __ ] because like the
like they was protesting right mm-hmm it
was just protesting for some somebody
somebody got killed or something well
there was the george floyd
yeah because of that too yeah it's been
they were doing all protest
crazy man cali's been a crazy place the
last uh couple of years um
and then yo so
you know the one thing about the bay too
that everyone is uh that's synonymous
with the bay right is bipping
bippin is kind of like um there's you'll
go to the bay and there's people who
just leave all their windows down
not even when you leave the window down
you know
the window but i'm saying they'll leave
the windows down because they're like
i'd rather you just come into my car and
see there's nothing in here then you
break my [ __ ] window and i have to
replace it yeah
yeah okay cool yeah uh
it actually happened to me not to me
personally but uh
roc nation had came to oakland um
they were trying to sign me and um the
guy had
i went to get something to eat and i
told him like
be cool like and they they went up the
street and got something to eat and like
when they someday walked in the store
they hit that [ __ ]
it's crazy crazy like but um
a lot of rappers though like they come
out different empire they always getting
their [ __ ] hit i got a lot of rappers
and got they jury took out the air and
all type of [ __ ] i think um
it's very easy to spot a rental car
um i mean we if you in that profession
yeah yeah yeah if you're in that
profession if you are not you know you
know what a rental is for sure yeah i
don't know it's crazy because we
was just driving the other day
we're downtown oakland we're like that's
the bippers right there and they're
driving around in the car just doing in
circles you could just you could just
knew we knew they're cool you know what
they're doing mm-hmm
yeah it's pretty crazy like um was it
because you know i feel like bipping in
the bay is kind of like you know i think
it isn't normal money off this [ __ ] it's
just normal i feel like it's kind of
like when we think of like people people
like people getting money in the streets
that's just rich off that [ __ ] that's
what i'm saying like crazy like
[ __ ] and called me with all
type of [ __ ] before like i'd be like i'm
gonna [ __ ] left this in a car
like
it's almost like opening a fortune
cookie like you never know what you're
gonna get [ __ ] in a car like that's
crazy i would never leave this [ __ ]
without saying obviously what's the
craziest thing you've heard someone
getting out of someone's car that's like
what the [ __ ] someone left that 200 000
um
like fo-fi watches
purses all type of [ __ ] like you imagine
leaving i was like damn who the [ __ ] is
this like is this like owner or
something someone left 200k in their car
a thousand i know some rappers from
empire and got robbed too without rob
got bipped too for that jury um
i got hit in burbank someone followed me
from the bank
i stopped at a ups
to get something notarized and i had 15
bands under my seat cash and they took
that [ __ ] i was sick
wait
they bipped the car yeah it blew up my
window i don't understand why people
leave [ __ ] like that in cars well bro
imagine i'm in burbank it don't matter
i'm keeping my [ __ ] on so so this is
where i'm at there's the ups store i
park like right there right
i'm in and out
you thought she was in there
they was in and out
i was sitting down i get on my like true
detective [ __ ]
i figure out that they followed me from
the bank of america
so before i went to bank of america or
after i went to bank of america i got
gas
so i [ __ ] paid the owner of the gas
station to give me the footage to see
the car that pulled in behind me and
waited and followed me out so i had like
a still of the kind of car
i [ __ ] found their trash they threw
away
he was on youtube they threw away
mcdonald's i tried to get the plate
number but i could it was too blurry bro
i was on my [ __ ] though i sent i had a
homie in chattanooga who works at a csi
thing i sent him the mcdonald's trash
from the fingerprints oh my god so i'm
like bro cause i'm thinking like i'm
gonna get this money back yeah i'm not
gonna deal with the cops because they
ain't gonna do [ __ ] so i'm like don't
let me find out who these people are
it's bad for them you know what i'm
saying and it just i was i was called
man
i almost had these [ __ ] bro i
was so ugh yeah you ain't supposed to be
um then never again but i think though
if they followed you from did all that
then they probably weren't just i'm
trying to bip you know what happened
that's what i'm saying so
that's that's a whole lot so once i
couldn't figure it out the cops they
said that um
a lady
followed me out of the bank a lady was
like she was like she kept like
resetting herself on the line because
you remember during covet
the bank lines were crazy
so the late there was a girl in the bank
who was just watching to see who was
walking out with money
and then she followed me out i got in
the car and then followed me out yeah i
like i didn't really
go to the line
call like order money and [ __ ] like that
yeah well
really what happened was i went there to
get to open a business account
and i brought the money to open the
account um we're supposed to open an
account for our publishing company
but my writer who i was opening with
owed the bank money
so they're like if he's going to be on
the account we can't give you the
account
so i pulled up with 15 bands
and i'm like well [ __ ]
i got all this money on me
um
can i just deposit this into my account
she's like yeah but you just gotta wait
in the line and i was like man [ __ ] all
this man i'm out like i ain't waiting in
this [ __ ] line i [ __ ] never i did
that before too but i'm kind of like
cool with the people now so never again
man yeah we got to stop the interview
right now uh listen man i got to say
about bluetooth our good folks at blue
chew one of our sponsors for the podcast
and a product that i use all right now
everyone thinks that you know maybe
taking a product like blue chew which
has the same active ingredients as
cialis and viagra is a thing it's not a
thing it's very normal you might have
anxiety you might have stress you need
that confident to get your [ __ ] on
alright trust me
you want to lay thor's hammer down on
that puss you know what i'm saying or
that butthole whatever you're into
let me tell you something best part
about blue chew not only is it in a
chewable form but you know when we think
about going to the doctor's office and
getting um a prescription for something
like this
we think about it as a maybe an
embarrassing conversation to have an
awkward conversation to have well
bluechu is an online prescription
service there's no visits to the
doctor's office that's right it ships
right to your door in a discrete package
and when i tell you bluechew helps you
if you're a man
achieve a harder and stronger erection
believe me when i say bud it's the
[ __ ] truth all right
it helps men combat all forms of ed all
right and let me tell you if you're
getting ready to go on a date
you just want to impress a young lady
you got to pop that blue chew man that'd
have your dick
you it might add a half an inch to your
dick your dick's never bits hard in your
[ __ ] life
i mean serious ain't being serious yo
even if you just want to jerk off and
just be like yo this is nice
it's [ __ ] amazing so
go over to blue chew it is a chewable
tablet you don't got to swallow it no
pills nothing like that bluetooth
licensed medical providers they work
with you they find the right ingredient
and the right strength for your
prescription it's so easy you go to
bluetooth.com consult with their
licensed medical providers and use the
promo code bootleg put it on the screen
bootleg at checkout all you got to do is
pay five dollar shipping and they're
gonna give you your first month of
bluetooth for free that's right you can
try blue chew for free go to
bluechew.com use the promo code bootleg
and receive your first month free
man oh man i am a user of the blue chew
and i [ __ ] with a shot shout out to
blue chew let's get back to the
interview um what else i mean obviously
you know with you and the label like
having 10 or 12 artists is a lot of
people to look over a lot of
people's lives a lot of careers
um
that's why i've been kind of like trying
to fall back for me doing the music so i
could like focus on you know a lot of
responsibility a lot of bandwidth for
sure how are you dealing with all that
man
i ain't gonna lie it's been it's been
easy
you know we just had fod weekend in
vegas i had rented out this big old
mansion or whatever like 21 rooms in it
we got a lot of work done a lot of
artists came producers um engineers shot
a lot of videos
um
just been doing different little things
like that to where i could like sit down
and really be hands-on with everything
and you know and uh explain how this
[ __ ] work
but um it's really been easy to keep it
real it ain't been too hard like
probably just like one artist here and
here yeah no i know i just know because
you know i work with artists and i know
it could be a lot it can be it can be
but you know me like
i've been doing this [ __ ] for so long so
i know how to like you know what i'm
saying like how to you're not doing it
by yourself you gotta you got a team i'm
sure me and chelsea yeah shout out to
chelsea yeah i mean chelsea that's who
you know who um who helped me with
everything and also my uh cameraman cm
cm deluxe oh that's dope uh-huh yeah
they just said i mean shout out to
empire uh the documentary that they did
about you was it last year it came out
last year
um phillip beasley album yeah yeah yeah
that was dope to kind of just see like
kind of behind the scenes like different
side of you
it was a lot more that we didn't use i
think we're gonna do another one um but
uh yeah
i just did that like i was kind of like
transitioning i was really trying to
fall back on doing the music myself
because i want to be able to give my
artist in the label 100
how many albums do you have
uh
in your catalog that
are are on spotify right now
i'm lost count
like give me like a over a hundred over
a hundred yeah i think i dropped 12
tapes in like one year to see if i could
do it and those are all on the dsps
mm-hmm jesus man
those twelve that came out that was all
empire
i've been putting out music like oh wait
so when you have that much catalog
because you know i always try to tell
artists if you're going to stay
independent like
a lot of times artists overthink [ __ ]
yeah and they never put music out or
they overthink it and they sit on their
hands too long it's like to me i'm like
yo run it up because that's your
residual income
what has been your biggest check off of
your catalog in a month you've done off
the streams if you don't mind i don't
want to be in your pocket
that's great man that's amazing like 75
000 it came i remember i first got my
first 5gs
and then
because i used to just put out just mix
tapes
i used to just run my mixtapes through
empire before i was at empire i was
dealing with on urban life at rap bay
you know
and i should just be
20 30
50.
and then uh
and then guys he started seeing the
numbers
he was like hey we need to do an album
just before i even did this
the first album i did with empires in
2016 real nigga's back in style
so he's like hey we need to do a single
and then and then base the singer around
the album
this is before i did the album
get it going so i just made that single
make a living with sue
and then i finally did the album other
than that i was just running mixtape
series sim city money man neighborhood
superstar just running through them
doing millions of views on the videos
and all that type of [ __ ] so
that [ __ ] and i think also back then
like youtube paid a lot more
yeah the youtube money was great back
then yeah it was a lot different because
the other what was dope about back then
was
if you had a distribution deal they
didn't touch your youtube money yeah so
you were getting the youtube bag over
here yeah and then itunes over here but
now it's all all combined into one which
i'm like damn
because that youtube money was great you
know so it paid way better than the
streaming [ __ ] yeah so that's how that
used to work too so
i mean you know
that's why i'm able to be you know like
i get paid 20 a show still to this day
you know what i'm saying i'm returning
10 15 a verse that's big so
you go to a city you post up i'm in the
city if you if you got your bag right
come get the version no i had a show in
kc not too long ago
[ __ ] before i even got in the club
somebody was in the front waiting into a
verse
so when i'm backing up security like hey
this guy right here want to talk to you
like what's up i'm trying to do it first
i'm like okay cool uh
he asked me the price
gave me the number he didn't even go on
the show he left when you go get the bag
together told me to pull up on him
when i was done with the show
i ended up pulling up on him after i was
done with the show so mind you i had a
meet and greet that day the show
the verse and then in the midst of me
doing the verse with him someone else
came and did a verse with him in a video
all in one night so i didn't get back to
the room till like like six in the
morning jesus just ran it up yeah all
that happened all in a day's worse that
[ __ ] like that be busy be doing and [ __ ]
like that and you know just on the road
just running that [ __ ] up type [ __ ] yeah
boozy is
he he don't care for sure he's a real
rap hustler [ __ ] rap hustling for
real
who's somebody who uh inspires you
because you're such
a boss you do your entrepreneurial [ __ ]
um but who's an artist or uh just
someone in the game that's inspired you
a lot that you get motivation from um i
[ __ ] with meek tough i [ __ ] with little
baby tough uh
ross i [ __ ] with anybody yep i [ __ ] with
anybody that's like you know inspiring
you i'm saying people i can relate to
people i can see you know that been
through something in and really you know
living a dream and
and
you know happy where they are in life
type [ __ ] i'm saying taking care of
their family
putting their [ __ ] in position you
know what i'm saying um and just
motivating a person to go harder you
know what i'm saying and never being
content with it
that's what i like i don't even check my
bank account
i will not like i will not look at it
why because i don't want to know what i
don't want to know because i don't want
to be content because if you see it you
might be like i could i could chill out
a little bit i don't want to do it like
you have someone checking your bank
account for you yeah i have accounting
okay they're doing it now because and
then
every time something gets spent it sends
me a text i got you but uh
i don't ever want to know what's in it
right to where i just like okay i got
five million i can just relax no i don't
never
like i get mad if something like i don't
even check the receipt like thinking
about this oh yeah i got you they gave
me a receipt i won't even look at it
like they asked me when we see i say no
that's funny yeah like i don't want to
be like
oh man i could just sit back and do
nothing right i just feel like at that
time being if you do then somebody else
can come in and take that spot like i
always want to work keep working harder
and harder and harder until whenever i
figured out i figured out but if
something i just
i won't do it
uh you uh obviously went through uh one
of the more
in my opinion dope rap beefs recently
because you guys kept it on vine on
record are you a mozzie it was both
songs recently that's oh that was like
three years ago two years ago i don't
know but it was to me it was like dope
because it reminded me of like
you know just some [ __ ] that i grew up
on people keeping [ __ ] up putting dope
songs out yeah
because i feel like nowadays man like we
saw king vaughn you know with that [ __ ]
with kwando i don't think he had a rap
beef with what
that's what i'm saying it wasn't even
like that's the weirdest thing about the
dirk and young boy thing i'm like you
guys aren't even from the same city i'm
so confused this is strictly some
hip-hop [ __ ] i think that [ __ ] was like
over a [ __ ] or something but i just
thought it was dope that like i i feel
like you guys did that [ __ ] the right
way because you guys have mutual homies
you guys got mutual business and you
guys had obviously a disagreement and it
ended up on record and yeah and it was
what it was and everyone moved on yeah
for sure uh you know me i don't i don't
have no grudges i ain't mad at nobody
what i'm saying like
i'm i've been doing my thing and i'm
continuing doing my thing you know so
should i don't wake up every day
thinking about you know
the past or anything else i'll be
focused on the future it's a beautiful
thing man
um when you like see some of these
younger artists
um
who you might [ __ ] with
we i feel like recently we've just seen
so much [ __ ] going on in terms of
just
people keeping one foot in one foot out
on the rap [ __ ] and you know we see
people losing their freedom
we see people losing their life we see a
lot so much going on like like what
would be some advice you would give to
some of those younger artists who maybe
haven't
i i tell my artists all the time not to
even make this records
not to even fall into the negativity and
understand this come with the music game
everybody's not going to like you it's
going to be a lot of
people from your past to remember i
remember he wasn't doing this i remember
he had his like hater type [ __ ] again
i'm saying so it comes with it you got
to have tough skin for it and if you
ain't ready for hate you ain't ready for
success but then also you got to
understand too when you
when you coming from the hood or the
trenches and you um
you give these kids money that never had
money before and they also had a street
mentality like it's like they feel like
they can't be touched
they don't really care about the certain
things that they should be worried about
until later on
you know i'm saying so that's like well
i never choose to um like pop ecstasy or
pills and [ __ ] like that because a lot
of people from my neighborhood used to
get high and then they'd wake up
not knowing what they did later on in in
in the interrogation room wow you know
what i'm saying they'd be like what the
[ __ ] happened last night
so like and i knew a lot of people from
my neighborhood lost their mind like
early like like young dudes like
20 years old like smoking crack now
because you know he didn't pop the bad
ecstasy pill and [ __ ] him off and this
was like a
fly [ __ ] i used to hoop and
get good grades in school you know what
i'm saying so i'm like man i don't never
want to play with myself like that you
know what i'm saying because i've seen
how you know just like how they doing it
right now how they pressing up the pills
they're fighting all type [ __ ] like that
people dying like this was back then
mm-hmm yeah i'm saying like it was the
hyphy movement days when
[ __ ] popping six xc pills losing their
mind right i'm saying like hell nah like
you never got down with that [ __ ] nah
never the only thing i ever did was
smoke weed sip syrup that was it
did you still sip nah i been stopping a
long time ago was that hard to stop
because i know some people say it's
pretty tough to get off no it wasn't
hard um
my whole thing i was i was abusing i was
getting too high it wasn't hard from
when i kicked it it was like
i they're like not paying attention when
i would be doing that damn they're
probably simple breaking the day
yeah i'm saying because i used to when i
used to buy a pint i used to have like
the 20 ounce cream sodas and now i pour
like a four in here and each one of them
and i don't drink like four of them and
i'm
[ __ ] off again i'm saying not even
knowing i shoot a video i actually i
shot a video somebody came in town paid
me for a verse in the video i shot the
video
i drunk one right here doing this scene
one at this scene one at this scene one
of this scene that's the whole brick yo
that's crazy because i'm not even paying
attention to what i'm doing it's so it's
so good but you know they say something
that something that's that good ain't
that too good for you
so uh
one day i woke up you know um
i walked up [ __ ] up one day and i was
like man if i make him man i'm done
and i just been done ever since damn
yeah that's good man yeah yeah i feel
like you know the lean thing is like
obviously like you said it's something
that people really enjoy but it's also
like it it's like your body can become
dependent on it and
it's just like if you're drinking a good
ass soda and
you just keep drinking that [ __ ] over
and over and you're gonna keep drinking
it but you're not knowing that the sugar
or whatever the caffeine or whatever is
[ __ ] you up inside you don't even
realize it until it gets something it's
too late yeah that's real [ __ ] you
talked about the rock nation [ __ ] um
i remember hearing about that i think i
think you told me about it before what
what made you initially um
not want to sign um shout out to roc
nation um
who's trying to sign you earl daniel
okay um
and i [ __ ] with daniel still to this day
uh
and not necessarily him is the one who
who wanted what they wanted but
he was the one who brought the situation
you know
together um but um
they just wanted the um a pass catalog
and the match it's a super no and that's
what the manual this was right before
covert so if i would have did that i
would have been paying them for nothing
so they wanted so so they wanted to sign
you
and then all your catalogs come bring
and that's [ __ ] crazy yeah and and it
was not just saying like we were going
to build this and we're going to tour
with this person
this and all this and all that and i was
just like
i'm like man we can start from here
like if you want to start from what's
going on
forever i can't do the back yeah
and luckily i didn't you know i'm saying
and shout out to like i said shout out
to roc nation for the opportunity but
they do a lot of artists like that and
they was naming off all the other
artists that got the same type of deals
and this and this yeah but that's not
that's not a good deal no not at all and
i don't know especially not for
independent artists that's been living
off music come on man to where now i
gotta wait for y'all and i gotta get
it's like damn y'all to have nothing to
do with these albums yeah and why would
you add all that red tape yeah to your
book right right before
right right after that i mean right
after that
uh the pandemic hit so it wasn't it
wouldn't have been no shows no nothing i
would have just been you would have been
stuck yeah because because you can't
just drop when you want now yeah no not
even that like the whole thing was they
was going to put me on tour
um i was supposed to be doing this and
doing that but all that was shut down
into the pandemic so i wouldn't even
been getting no money i've been giving
you all money for free thank god that um
yeah yeah you would have just been yeah
what where's the perks there
that's crazy
yo we got to stop the interview real
quick shout out to our presenting
sponsor odd socks baby hey man listen
all i keep on my ass is odd socks draws
all i keep on my feet are socks you know
why because they're the most comfortable
socks in the world
and i'm not just saying this because
they promote the podcast i'm telling you
the socks are crazy uh they got all the
licenses look they got halloween socks
they have back to the future socks
they got [ __ ] twizzler socks
old dirty bastard socks r.i.p to odb
alright they also got their draws if you
want to wear some underwear with pizza
on them whatever you need but my
favorite are the odd socks basics baby
these are just the plain boys these to
me are the most comfortable socks in the
world all right
so trust me when i say go to
oddssoxofficial.com
thank me later when you go to check out
buying the most comfortable socks in the
world
get some wwe socks too i just saw a
sneak peek of the new wwe line and
they're [ __ ] insane
in [ __ ] sane uh go to
oddssocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg kev that's one word together
bootleg kev
we should talk to them about shortening
that bootleg cab is the promo code you
will get 20 percent off at checkout one
more time go to ostoxofficial.com save
20 off using that promo code bootleg kev
let's get back to the interview yeah any
artist if you have catalog and you try
to sign a deal and
now it's different if they just say we
just want to distribute it you know yeah
because that's a different situation but
if they're like no bring bring your
catalog over to our label yeah
that they're uh go go [ __ ] yourself it's
the shortest you gotta understand too so
how i look at it as you know a lot of
people that complain about it are just
putting out too much music i'm not
assigned to a record label so why would
i not put out as much as you can because
that's where i get paid from so it's a
numbers game man yeah so if i'm getting
paid
whatever i'm getting paid off each album
why would i not keep dropping it's a
numbers game like when you're on a major
they want you to drop an album then tour
a year and then come back and drop then
because they putting the money up before
you and and everything else you got to
move at their pace yeah they can tell
you what song they don't want on there
what picture they don't want i didn't
heard artists like okay they want me to
sign over here but they wanted me to
take off my tattoos or cut my dreads and
[ __ ] like that i don't want to control
you cause they putting the money up so
they want you to look a certain way they
want you to wrap a certain way this is
what they feel will work
i feel like artists nowadays are
at least becoming more
transparent and understanding that they
might be in shitty deals yeah and
venting that you know like we've seen
meek we've seen yg we've seen a lot of
people be like
yo i didn't get no money off my music
because what happens is you take the
advance
and that has to if you take if you get a
million that's just an easy number to
work with
a million dollars on a major label
you're probably only owning
seven to twelve percent of your using so
much just to get that million back
because they're going you got to make
that [ __ ] back over 10 times before you
recoup it's like bro that's hard to do
yeah so that's where all the other
things the endorsements and everything
else come in that's what they living off
of in the shows and [ __ ] yeah but when
that [ __ ] dries up that's where you
would see these artists during the
pandemic like man [ __ ] my label i see no
money since and then they get back
trapping again and then they get caught
up and then they go to jail nah i think
that's really what kovitt did was it
made y'all realize yo no all these
[ __ ] for the most part you know
and these are good guys i [ __ ] with a
lot of them but when you
take that easy upfront check
you're signing off on a lot of [ __ ]
in that deal yeah
yeah i mean you got to make that thing
[ __ ] yeah if they make that they're
giving you that they're going to tell
your friend what they want back
and yeah and i don't feel bad for nope
bro i don't feel bad because you've
signed the [ __ ] deal
like you we're talking grown ass man you
signed a contract yeah like you you
either you needed the money you didn't
take in advance before
it took advantage but it's different
it's d i feel like
it's it's a it's a it's different splits
yeah yeah it's different but you can't
sell your soul you know i didn't take in
advance before but i made money back i
recoup so yeah that's how it works see
now a lot of them
take the advantage imagine if [ __ ] it
off oh imagine if you only get eight
percent how hard it is to recoup that
now if you do like a distro situation
and you got a 80 20 60 40 90 10 whatever
it's a lot easier to recoup but if you
have eight percent out of a hundred yeah
that means 92 pennies of every dollar
goes into the label's pocket and only
eight cents
and you don't get the eight that eight
cents goes towards your balance that you
owe that you owe me go and go in your
pocket it does not go in your pocket you
gotta [ __ ] forever to pay that [ __ ] off
forever
you gotta be [ __ ] the weeknd or
somebody you know what i mean you gotta
be
drake like you know what i mean like
it's like good luck you know i don't
think people understand like when you
look at you know i'd be looking at
people's numbers except like okay if he
did 20 million streams times
20 times 4 000
i mean [ __ ] you know i mean like
i mean that's cool money you know i mean
but like
you know like how are you what's your
overhead yeah yeah yeah what's your
overhead a lot of these you gotta
understand too a lot of these rappers uh
like that's all they ever did was rap
so they don't have any really other
hustles or whatever so like if they get
that money and [ __ ] that money off it's
over
and it happens more often than not yeah
you know especially your first deal most
people's first deal is all bad
go buy chains
bring all the homies on the road
[ __ ] all of all the drugs all this [ __ ]
man
are you pretty um
like do you do you travel deep or like
did you move around with a lot of people
or um
like in like home or you talking about
like out of town let's say you out of
town for my rider it's like um
four rooms and five flights that's not
bad yeah
yeah that's not bad
i recently tried to book an artist for a
show or for a club and they wanted 15
flights
and uh
i was like well this isn't going to work
guys yeah no i seen some [ __ ] like that
i booked for a show
with an artist
before and uh that [ __ ] [ __ ] was crazy
it was like um
he wanted
25 chicken wings 50 lobster tails he
wanted
like some crazy [ __ ] didn't even eat
none of it that's how it worked and came
there and counted it like he came to the
and came there encountered this [ __ ]
like i didn't book him i was on the show
with him but the guy was telling me like
his writer how crazy his [ __ ] was but
you know if you're the promoter you
agree to i could say hey i want five
latino women in the room but as naked
rolling blunts for me and um i want
a gallon of a gallon of um eminem's all
green and if you agree to it you got to
provide how to provide it that's real
it's up to you yeah there it is man um
all right well look the album is out
motivational purposes
uh hey talk about the april slate of
your artist that you got dropping um so
april
first i'm i'm if i'm almost done friday
next friday uh we got two bands dropping
hbo2 i met him nice guy funny guy yeah
um skinny t just dropped
just bang just dropped uh we got loso we
got a little steve we got a little tray
uh we got roscoe fetty he just dropped
you know we got my nephew he's 12 years
old j money oh [ __ ] yeah he just dropped
the tape are you helping him
no
right
don't he write it on you write his own
[ __ ] where everything is
got videos he do everything and so he
he
he one of a kind that's [ __ ] that's
lit yeah yeah yeah so um we're just
working man we just um i'm about to drop
a
fod compilation album okay on may 9th
it's called the infrastructure filthy
race presents fod so i like that that's
the next big move for everybody got the
whole label on there so and then from
there we just
just pushing out tapes i think skinny
and steve i mean skinny and steve got
album coming out uh
stuck on seminary four
tuta and skinny got out i'm coming out
uh cartiers and rolexes
um
and we got wipe day out of sacramento he
the next thing up by the sack shout out
to zach yeah for sure shout out to
stockton too stockton's yeah right now
with the evk movement yeah yeah we got
um we got slobby on the album too and uh
fod infrastructure
so um
lots about it a lot of good work it's
gonna be a busy year yeah it's never not
a busy year for you got to man what was
your calmest year in the last 10 years
where you were like like where you put
out the least amount of music
maybe last year last year it was like
two tapes
maybe three no it was three it was a
it was a phillip beasley
and i had a group album with um tuta
and then uh
solidified
so there's only three tapes that year
most people can't get three tapes out in
their whole [ __ ] career so yeah other
than that everything else been turned to
there it is man appreciate you pulling
up appreciate you man you're out on this
team yeah i'm coming through your
motivational purpose make sure y'all go
get you a english bulldog yeah your
english bulldog real bullies back in
style may 9th is the fod project
infrastructure dropping may 9th man we
uh
we're trying to take this [ __ ] over man
we don't know no limit man new no limit
i like it let's go